in in the gut microbiome business so
because we I mean now we are talking so
much about the gut microbiome and then
there are a couple of companies who are
you know testing at microbiome through
stool tests uh and there are a lot of
kits available where you can collect
this tools send it back to the lab and
then they they do sequencing and then
come up with your uh uh come up with the
report which talks about what kind of
bacteria you have what kind of and based
on the bacterias they also provide you
know nutrition uh uh recommendation or
supplements or or probiotics so yeah
depending on you know what suits a
person but then still there there is
looks like there's a lot of challenges
in the gut microbiome business
uh so I've divided into you know like
accessibility affordability and
actionability so coming to the
accessibility not everyone has access to
the test right like a of course in the
U.S uh in in Western countries things
are a little better but if you look at
here there's not much uh companies who
are doing this test and not many people
are aware so I think awareness is a big
uh trouble over here so so to build
anything around this to build a product
or to build a you know uh anything
around gut microbiome the first thing
what one have to do is to create that
awareness that how it is important why
it is important and how it is related to
multiple disease like diabetes like IBD
so that awareness creation itself is a
it's it's a you know
uh uh it it it's a
Milestone one have to reach or maybe
we'll have to wait for the market to
actually get there so so that's one then
then the cost yes the the cost of any
sequence in gut microbiome sequence is
much higher today in today's scenario I
don't know if anyone aware we can
discuss of the you know the range of the
the cost which goes from uh 10K to 25k
in India while in in Western it could be
you know from 150 to 300 to 500
depending on what test you are taking so
so yes cost is a big uh limitation for
any of the gut microbiome test there's
no insurance coverage no doctor would
recommend this test as one of the uh
diagnostic tests for for any Source any
disease right so so so that's another
big problem because there are no layers
there are no support from it government
from you know uh hospital or or or the
the whole ecosystem so there has to be a
I mean going forward in future I uh I
would hope that there there is more
ecosystem developed around the gut
microbiome so the so the company get
incentive to do it or the doctor gets
incentive to to recommend it and
obviously the users who are going to do
it uh it shouldn't be an out-of-pocket
expenses it it can come through the
insurance or any other you know ways to
to reimburse that cost of the gut
microbiome
so no employer uh reimbursement no not
FDA approved that's another challenge
with obviously for clinicians anything
to recommend as a diagnostic test they
need an FDA approved uh you know product
but as of now uh this is not FDA
approved so yes uh that's another
challenge direct to Consumer genetic
test they also face regulatory huddles
in different markets different markets
has their different requirements a lack
of distribution channels so these are
accessibility coming to the
affordability most tests are paid out of
pocket gut health program with
personalized nutrition counselors are
very very expensive uh diet
recommendations are not personalized to
the Target consumers Financial
situations uh cost per test is
prohibitive for new customer
acquisitions
uh subscription model are not very
popular on this uh you know subscription
model works most in in most areas but
not in this case most take the test one
time out of the Curiosity I have gone
through the test but yeah I I don't
think that I will go through it again
because I you know I did not find uh
what I was looking for it so so so the
whole subscription model doesn't seems
to be working shipping and Logistics is
another challenge because of the uh the
cost which goes under uh you know the
whole whole kit and the logistic in in
the logistic
uh again the actionability yes relevance
to the test report relevance to
enterotypes uh report uh contradicts
consumers or the users diet Behavior so
for me it said something which I have
never had so I think I am like okay and
what is this happening this is not
actually my report this is not
personalized to me so there is a gap in
the actionability or the action items as
well uh nutrition advice is too generic
there is a lack of personalization
customers are not happy basically with
the gut health report due to the
mismatch in the test findings and the
the actual
uh what they're looking for uh then you
have yeah again like the nutrition
counseling the experts with good subject
matters are are really needed so we
don't have enough uh you know evangelist
or the nutrition counselors nutritionist
who who talks about or and and who
implement or who adopt these whole gut
microbiome they are too generic they
they just take your you know uh
lifestyle history but they did really
not focus on the the the the gut side of
the house